cultural appropriation have you heard of
that cultural appropriation the latest
no no now again in my day it was
considered a good thing to swap ideas
with other cultures with other nations
to share things with other races to
assimilate it was the opposite of racist
now it's racist Gwen Stefani got in
trouble in her last video CU she had her
blonde hair in dreadlocks people go no
black people invented dreadlocks you
can't have them you're white that's
racist Jamie Oliver got in trouble when
he put out authentic jerk chicken recipe
go no black people invented that you
can't have it you're white that's racist
now black people they use the nword
don't they we invented
that